♪ ♪ ♪
- Béatrice Martin, alias Coeur
de pirate, est à la fois artiste
et gestionnaire depuis qu'elle
a fait l'acquisition, il y a
six mois, de l'étiquette
Dare To Care Records.
BÉATRICE MARTIN-COEUR DE PIRATE,
autrice-compositrice-interprète
- En fait, ça va super bien.
Des fois, je me surprends moi-
même en me disant qu'il y a
des... Je suis comme : OK,
d'accord, j'ai plus de sang-
froid que je pensais.
- Avec son étiquette désormais
baptisée Bravo Musique,
Coeur de pirate fait partie
du nombre grandissant de femmes
qui veulent gérer l'industrie
musicale d'ici, un artiste
à la fois.
- Moi, j'apporte la confiance
nécessaire pour que cet artiste-
là se développe, t'sais. Un peu
comme ce qu'on a fait avec moi,
finalement.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La pianiste Alexandra
Stréliski est aussi
entrepreneure. Elle est devenue
actionnaire du studio Lamajeure.
ALEXANDRA STRÉLISKI,
compositrice-interprète
- Je l'ai fait dans un soucis
de... premièrement, pour assumer
mon côté entrepreneurial,
parce que je pense que souvent,
les femmes n'assument pas
forcément leur côté
entrepreneurial. Et quand on
l'a, cette fibre-là, ça prend
le courage et ça prend la mise
en action.
♪ Tout pour nous ♪
♪ Tout à nous ♪
- Cette volonté de s'investir
et d'être à la tête de sa propre
entreprise est de plus en plus
présente. Catherine Simard a
fondé La maison fauve. Et parmi
ses artistes, on retrouve
entre autres Patrice Michaud,
Vincent Vallières et Eli Rose.
CATHERINE SIMARD,
présidente, La maison fauve
- J'étais rendue à un point
dans ma vie où j'avais plus
envie de demander de permissions
à personne. J'avais envie
de faire mes propres choses.
Moi, je sens, dans la dernière
année surtout, qu'il y a eu un
vent de changement. Les femmes
sont de plus en plus visibles.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce vent de changement chez
les gestionnaires bénéficie
aux artistes féminines, comme
celles de chez Bravo Musique.
MAUDE AUDET, autrice-
compositrice-interprète
- C'est beau de donner la chance
aussi, puis pas juste de donner
la chance, de donner la place
que ces femmes-là méritent,
en fait.
THAÏS MILLET, autrice-
compositrice-interprète
- Le talent, je pense qu'il a
toujours été là, c'est juste que
là, on a une tribune peut-être
plus grande pour le montrer.
- Malgré ce bel élan,
il y aurait encore beaucoup
de chemin à parcourir.
- Si tu regardes le conseil
d'administration de l'ADISQ,
c'est majoritairement des
hommes. En ce moment, on est
rendus à un point où ça prend
un petit peu peut-être des fois
de discrimination positive pour
rétablir l'équilibre des choses.
- Moi, j'ai envie juste
d'encourager celles qui l'ont,
cette fibre-là, à la mettre
en action.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Des voix féminines s'élèvent
dans la musique d'ici et leurs
échos résonnent au diapason.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪ ♪ ♪